little liechtenstein
nope not luxembourg down a bit yes that
small one
lichtenstein or the principality of
liechtenstein
is a small german-speaking country
surrounded
by austria to the east and switzerland
to the west
it is the fourth smallest country in
europe in both land
area and population but
why does this tiny country even exist
and how has it stayed independent for so
long
[Music]
liechtenstein like other microstates in
europe has a reputation for being a rich
tax haven for foreign billionaires
though it has been working to rid itself
of that image
it's a semi-constitutional monarchy
being ruled by the prince of
liechtenstein in concert with parliament
the prince is known to be one of the
most powerful monarchs in europe having
the power to veto legislation
appoint judges and dismiss government
ministers
so how did this small rich and frankly
unusual country come to be well it all
started in the 18th century
in the holy roman empire the holy roman
empire is a pretty complex topic that
historians
still argue about today but basically it
was a political entity made up
of a myriad of small mostly
german-speaking kingdoms
principalities duchies and the like that
were all under the authority of the holy
roman emperor
a position created whole cloth by the
pope in rome
the complexities of the empire aren't
quite in the purview of this video
but you do need to know the basics of
its political system
so the different segments of the empire
if powerful and
important enough would be given
representation in the imperial diet
or reichstag think of it similar to a
senate or
parliament where representatives of
different regions meet to make decisions
of course in this case the
representatives were wealthy land-owning
nobles who earned their positions by
being born into them instead of
democratically elected politicians
but whatever also the diet was not a
legislative body
but more a council of advisors for the
emperor
so back to liechtenstein nope not the
land
but the family the house of luchenstein
was a minor
noble family of the holy roman empire
they got their name from castle
liechtenstein
where they had resided in the middle
ages which is now ironically
in austria anyway the family was rich
and powerful
but they didn't have a seat in the reich
dog you see to earn a seat in the diet
you had to meet two criteria one the
emperor had to grant a seat to you
and two the family had to enjoy what's
called immediacy
what that meant was that the land they
owned had to have no authority above it
save the emperor himself the house of
liechtenstein did indeed
own land but their lands were
technically in the dominions of the
habsburgs
this all gets into the confusing legal
nature of
feudalism and fiefdoms but all you need
to know is that the liechtenstein family
didn't meet the requirements for an
imperial seat
so in the early 1700s the head of the
house of liechtenstein
hans adams the first bought two small
counties called baduts and schellenberg
from another noble family the house of
hohenems
this purchase was all that was needed to
give the liechtenstein family a seat at
the reichdog
and in 1719 emperor charles vi
combined vaduz and schellenberg into the
principality of liechtenstein
naming it after the noble family that
had recently bought it
it's important to understand that the
princes of liechtenstein bought the land
for
political expediency they resided in
vienna
and continued to do so after they became
the rulers of liechtenstein
in fact the family didn't step foot in
the land for about a hundred years after
they bought it
so that's how the country got its start
as a small principality of the holy
roman empire
in 1806 the holy roman empire fell to
french forces led by napoleon bonaparte
napoleon then created the confederation
of the rhine
a replacement state that was under the
thumb of the empire of france
liechtenstein along with many of the
former imperial estates
joined this new confederation but it
fell apart 10 years later and was
replaced with the new
german confederation the german
confederation was
similar to the holy roman empire in that
it was a loose union between the small
german states
but was even less cohesive due to its
having no real ruler
also the two main german powers prussia
and austria didn't want it to become its
own unified country
they had a number of conflicts to see
who would control the german lands
and in 1866 prussia won that debate in
the seven weeks war
prussia then gobbled up all of the other
states one by one
until the german empire was finally
established in 1871
but liechtenstein did not join the new
german empire
it stayed independent even after the
fall of the german confederation
why well there are two main reasons
the first is simple geography i mean
look at europe at this time
austria who had not joined the new
empire had lands
here above liechtenstein if lieutenstein
had joined germany
it would have been a strange little
enclave
the second reason was that liechtenstein
had always been closer politically and
culturally
with austria this makes sense seen as
the princes of liechtenstein were
austrian and still at this point lived
in vienna
so why didn't austria take it over well
honestly there's no answer to that
austria had no interest in annexing it
and lichtenstein had no interest in
merging with austria
so yeah in many ways liechtenstein
managed to stay independent
basically by laying low it didn't fight
to stay independent
it didn't even have an army and still
doesn't
during world war 1 liechtenstein turned
away from austria
who as the austro-hungarian empire was
entrenched in war
and towards switzerland it joined a
monetary and defensive union with the
country
and has been close to it ever since
internationally
liechtenstein may as well be a part of
switzerland and i honestly wouldn't be
surprised if it merged with switzerland
in the future though i wouldn't
necessarily bet on it
the principality of liechtenstein is a
fascinating vestige of europe's
feudal past before the rise of the
nation-state
when most land was ruled by small noble
families
or huge multi-ethnic empires in today's
world it is a strange phenomenon
but seeing now the small nation's
prosperity and success
it shows us that perhaps bigger is not
always better
thank you very much for watching if you
haven't already please subscribe to the
channel
and if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up and leave a comment letting me
know what you think
bye